elles sont considérées comme des
violations en règle de la constitution
américaine les lois d'exception est
signée par george bush junior après les
attaques du 11 septembre sont toujours
en vigueur aux états unis un dispositif
de lutte antiterroriste inédit et dans
son fondement et surtout dans sa durée
condamné à maintes reprises pour ses
dérapages un surveillance de masse ou
détentions arbitraires des pratiques
controversées qui se poursuivent
toujours vingt ans après sous la
présidence de joe weise nous voyait là
est la correspondante à washington de
notre journaliste thomas bonnin
c'était le 26 octobre 2001 soit 45 jours
seulement après les attentats du 11
septembre de la même année le patriot
act été adoptée par les états unis une
série de mesures visant notamment à
étendre les possibilités de surveillance
par les agences de renseignement
les perquisitions et les saisies de
biens sont également rendus plus faciles
pour les autorités américaines de l'aveu
même de certains parlementaires de
l'époque à cette loi a été adoptée à la
va vite sans véritable débat de fond et
puis en 2013 il ya les révélations
notamment celle d'edouard snowdon autour
de la surveillance de masse s'effectuer
par la nsa en vertu de ce patriot act
une partie de l'opinion américaine
comprend à ce moment là qu au delà de la
lutte contre le terrorisme ce patriot
act est utilisé à d'autres fins
inquiétude partagée également par l'un
des auteurs du texte du patriot act
écoutez en tant qu'auteur du patriot act
je suis extrêmement perturbé par ce qui
apparaît comme une interprétation
exagérée de la loi le fbi a il a invoqué
pour une décision de justice top secrète
afin de recueillir les données
téléphoniques de potentiellement chaque
appel qui a été passée par les millions
de clients de verizon ces rapports sont
profondément inquiétants et soulève des
questions sur la sécurité de nos droits
constitutionnels
ce même auteur s'offusquait encore la
semaine dernière des dérives engendrées
par ce patriot act il ya une polémique
aux états unis depuis plusieurs semaines
sur le contenu des programmes scolaires
et c'est dans le cadre de cette
polémique qu'une association de comités
directeurs d'établissements scolaires a
adressé un courrier à joe biden ils se
plaignent à des pressions des menaces
que font certains parents d'élèves
justement à l'encontre de ces comités
directeurs ils qualifient ces actes de
terrorisme intérieur et en appelle donc
à l'utilisation du patriot act pour
poursuivre ses parents d'élèves
évidemment l'auteur explique que ce
n'était absolument pas l'idée de ce
texte adopté en 2001 si bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a les progressistes
certains progressistes et certains
conservateurs qui pour des raisons
différentes alertes donc sur les dérives
de ce patriot act une loi votée donc il
y a 20 ans et qui a surtout ouvert la
voie à d'autres législations similaires
dans d'autres pays des lois souvent
adoptée au lendemain d'attentats dans
ces pays et qui sont inscrits de fait
dans l'arsenal judiciaire à long terme
de ces pays souvent sans débat de fond
et sans remise en question